Speaker 1: Let's do some good news today.
We are really starting to crush the coronavirus,
my friends.
We are really doing it.
Check out some of these beautiful numbers.
Now, this doesn't mean it's over.
People, they're still suffering.
People are still dying.
But we are seeing numbers go very much in
the correct direction.
Coronavirus cases in the United States, which
peaked in mid-January at two hundred fifty
five thousand cases per day, are now down
to twenty five thousand cases per day.
That's a decline of more than 90 percent in
New Delhi cases.
Coronavirus deaths, which peaked in late January
at more than thirty four hundred a day.
9/11 plus 10 percent every day.
That's where we were in late January.
Those are now down below five hundred and
fifty a day, the lowest numbers going all
the way back to July of twenty twenty.
Still too many.
But importantly, once we get down to about
300 a day, you're really talking about something
that has gotten below the level of your typical
flu season.
We're not there yet, but we are going in that
direction now.
In the more heavily vaccinated states, the
numbers of covid deaths are already down to
roughly the average flu deaths in a normal
flu season.
As an example in the state or commonwealth
of Massachusetts, on many recent days, they
are seeing seven covid deaths, five covid
deaths, zero one day to another 12 another.
In a normal flu season, you see four to five
flu deaths a day in Massachusetts.
We are getting down to that level.
In some states, this does not mean it's over,
but it does mean that at the current level
of vaccination, we're getting very close to
crushing it completely.
Now, as a reminder, while we are seeing this
level of case decline while only having thirty
nine percent of the US population totally
vaccinated, we are going to see a much more
significant decline as we get to 50 and beyond.
Percent of vaccinated people cases have already
dropped 90 percent.
We are only thirty nine percent fully vaccinated
in the United States.
When we get to 50 percent vaccination, these
numbers will be even lower.
I think we will have no trouble getting to
50.
I think we'll have not much trouble getting
to 60 percent once we get beyond 60.
It's going to depend on how much anti vaccine
sentiment we can do away with because that
will be a problem.
There is going to be this limit.
Roughly 20 percent of the country doesn't
want the vaccine.
And you have to assume that on top of that,
there are people who sort of casually want
it, but they won't go and actually get it.
So that is going to be a challenge once we
get beyond 60 percent.
But by the Fourth of July, things are going
to be looking really, really good.
Now, as a reminder, my prediction was under
twenty thousand cases a day by Memorial Day.
We're five days away.
I think it's going to be close.
I think we're going to be right there.
We essentially we're at twenty five a day
right now and we have five days to go.
So we need to shed a thousand cases a day
between now and Memorial Day.
Lastly, of course, this is a global pandemic
and it's a global effort.
I'm glad to finally be able to say the global
cases and deaths are continuing down from
the global peak of about eight hundred and
thirty thousand cases per day in early April.
We are now down to about five hundred and
eighty thousand cases per day globally.
Still a crazy number, but a decline of about
30 percent in global cases.
Global deaths down about 17 percent from their
peak, still lagging.
No doubt a lot of people are dying.
But you'd rather be at this number and heading
down than at this number and heading up.
So let's keep things going.
Let's keep getting ourselves vaccinated.
We are really seeing the light at the end
of the tunnel.
We had a great conversation yesterday with
infectious disease doctor Isaac BOE.
Gosh, he was optimistic.
Check that out if you missed yesterday's podcast.
And we are going to have to now.
I mean, listen, I know I say to say this,
we are the envy of the world in terms of vaccine
availability.
There are countries desperate for vaccines.
They get one hundred thousand and they are
thrilled.
And we have millions and millions.
We've we've already done hundreds of millions
of doses.
They're available.
Just walk in.
It's hard it's hard not to get a vaccine at
this point.
You can get them so many places and still
so many people are just not doing it.
Let's do that.
We're going in the right direction.
Let's do it.
However, there are still deaths, despite what
Lauren Bobert recently claimed.
Let's talk about that next.